hi everyone welcome I think I know half
of the audience here so please raise
your hand if you already know me because
I it's kinda like okay perfect this is
the this is the perfect case scenario
where you have a friendly audience with
you so please laugh with all my jokes
and make very very simple questions so
so for those who don't know me welcome
my name is Ignacio or natural I am in
the Google Play team business
development manager I'm based in London
and I'm working with mobile game
developers and so today we're going to
talk about lifetime so thanks a lot for
coming because I know there's very high
competition very tough competition and
very good sessions at this very same
time I think my colleagues are doing a
great job so the fact that you're here
I'll I'll try to make the most out of
this session and the session is going to
last for 25 minutes and it's going to be
recorded so you can watch it later on
this is the agenda and then we're just
gonna cover some points and I don't have
the answer to the lifetime value in the
equation and and let's say that the
million dollar question which is how we
make money but I hope that the session
today will help you to kind of like
understand this topic and hopefully take
some decisions in the future and and
it's useful for you so the first the
first question is like why LTV and why
everyone is talking about lifetime value
so I I'm not gonna spend too much time I
think we all know that these days
everyone is talking about lifetime value
for a couple of reasons first and well
mostly the the technology is enabling to
track more things and we kind of like
track much much more more behaviors
rather than just installs we also see
that in games analytics then it's
becoming more relevant and probably you
have all data analysts within your your
team or your company but also like the
whole ecosystem that graph over there
we've seen it a number of times already
where revenues and usage are increasing
but install seems to be stagnating or at
least stabilizing which means that we
need to make more out of our users and
then we need to think about other
metrics maybe metrics that before they
didn't have so much relevance
such as like long-term retention dane ID
or day 180 they become more relevant
nowadays and also lifetime value so just
to get on the same page let's think
about like what lifetime value it is
because i think we all agree that
lifetime value is kind of like the
expected revenues that our users are
going to generate in the lifetime of the
of the game however we do not agree in
many other things for example the way to
calculate lifetime value nobody agrees
everyone has their own custom way and
probably it's actually right so that's
one thing that we need to take into
account when we are talking to someone
about lifetime value it might be very
different from your calculation a couple
of other things so for example we have a
crystal ball illustrating this slide
which means that we are predicting the
future and predicting the future means
that we are not going to be accurate
this is not an accurate science and
therefore we need to think about in
terms of like what is my error or
interval our confidence and therefore
what kind of what is going to be the
range of of my lifetime volume and then
two last things which would be dynamic
metric so my lifetime value changes over
time and this we've seen it not only
with external factors let's imagine that
we have a competitor launching a similar
game and then all of the sudden my users
fly but also like internally we can
affect this lifetime value by I don't
know releasing new functionalities or
new live ops which are going to help to
increase it hopefully and then last one
is a metric so it doesn't mean that by
having a very high lifetime value you're
gonna have a string a la and competitive
advantage over the rest and therefore we
need to think about like this is just a
useful metric that is gonna help us so
what are the usages so the first I think
it's clear right if we understand the
lifetime value we can understand what
are the costs and therefore we can think
about like what is a profitability for
every user and this is very much related
to user acquisition and it's been used
most of the times in in terms of like
driving campaigns or UAE campaigns where
we actually know how much are we going
to spend or at least what is our limit
to for expenditure in campaigns however
two other ideas which my conversations
with developers they haven't been
use that much would be to think about
lifetime value also for live ups so when
we release a new functionality or new
feature within the game this might have
an impact in engagement but also in
monetization so sometimes we might see
that the increase in ingame in
engagement might offset the increase or
by a decrease in monetization so the net
the net effect of that functionality is
actually zero for lifetime value so you
can think about this way also for for
pipeline thinking about like new games
if we start looking at this data from
the very beginning and we have enough
data we can think about like a method or
taking into consideration these this
metric by deciding a game so once we
have these what I've done is to classify
I spoke and I'm talking about popular
ways here because I spoke to many of you
actually we're sitting here and I want
to thank at this point like for
participating in these interviews that I
run for the last couple of months and
basically I was asking like developers
we are working in a regular basis what
are the ways that they are calculating
lifetime value and what we're going to
do is just like basically classify these
ways share some of these insights that
you basically share with us and try to
figure out like which ways might be more
relevant or more interesting for your
actual game so the first thing is like
one common thing that we see in the
lifetime value is that either we are
talking about retention or like lifetime
a lifetime variable or we are talking
about a monetization variable in this
case but when it comes to life can we
again do not agree because if you think
about retention many of you might take
retention has the classic retention
right
however some developers they were
talking to me and the saying like well
in my game it makes more sense to
consider rolling retention or range
retentions because there are episodes
and I'm launching a new season things
like that for example or daily vs.
arleigh why in a casual game it might
not make sense actually to look at daily
retention but hourly retention because
that's where we're when we are losing
the gate the user is very very fast also
collect daily rewards versus play a
battle as of today
tension is defined by opening the app
but what about like there's a big
difference between opening the app just
to collect a daily reward or actually
playing a bottom the same it stands for
monetization most of the times is our
Dow our PPO or our pool but in this case
also how do you calculate the ARB Dow is
gonna make a difference
am i taking the last week or the last
three months because it might have a
difference so when I am talking to
developers and I'm asking them about
like lifetime value I'm gonna have all
these things into consideration and it
would be interesting for you to think
before you are calculating it another
common thing that most developers have
is the period and this is interesting
because like it depends a lot
independently in a couple of metrics how
are we going to calculate the period
like the lifetime value is it going to
be 4 90 180 days 1 year or even like 5
years it might depend a lot in some key
factors so out of those conversations we
realize that things like for example
type of the game which are make make
sense like if it is a hardcore or casual
I might like to look at longer lifetime
values if it is a hardcore game the
business model that I'm using the state
of the company and it all comes down to
the funding so do I need to recover the
investment in 90 days or do I need to
recover it in maybe 365 so these things
are also quite interesting because every
company they calculated in a different
way depending on some of these aspects
there are more aspects by the way but
these are the ones that I just wanted to
highlight so let's think about then how
we classify all the ways that developers
nowadays are estimating lifetime value
so I just put an axis there on the on
the Left axis complexity and then
accuracy because I'm assuming that the
more complex you go the more accurate
your gonna be that's a priori because we
can see that sometimes you can go as
complex as you want and the accuracy
might not increase but let's let's
assume that the first one would be very
simple historical averages or benchmarks
that could be an easy way to estimate
called lifetime value then we will see
simple predictive models a little bit
more advanced predictive models and then
well the super hyper advanced predictive
models I'm not
cover them because they're usually
involving like behavioral patterns they
are involving like specific things to
the game so if we look at the three
first models the first one is quite easy
and talking to you we are not even
looking at predictive we are looking at
just looking at our historical data if
we have the data and maybe just
assessing like the are pool of the last
180 days if my game has been released
six months ago was X amount and I can
basically estimate with a new user at
day three is generating 70% and then I
will just project and 100% would be a
day 180 that's very simple and to be
honest has some pros which is like very
easy to estimate it has also some like
well enables quick decisions at very
early stages but on the other hand is
very it's not very precise and the
averages might kind of like buy us these
results by the way if you don't have
data most of developers what they're
doing then it's looking at like
benchmarks or maybe similar games that
you have in your portfolio and then you
say like well in my previous game
I was generating X amount so what is the
simple predictive so when we talk about
simple predictive models we we see both
two models which are quite used the
first one is the the kind of like the
top-down because we are looking at all
users and then we are just going to
estimate the lifetime value with this
formula you probably seen it away like
in some places and we are projecting the
retention which is the typical cube
survival cube and then we look at like
well at a hundred and eighty in this
case the retention is only 5% so on
average nine days per user are going to
use my lap if I multiply this by they
are tau then I can have in this case
0.45 dollars would be the retention they
lifetime value expectation for this for
this particular segment of users a
couple of pros relatively easy to
calculate there's a number of
spreadsheets online that you can
download and then the cons are is not
very accurate again because we are
taking segments and it depends like from
conversations that we have the source of
traffic might vary a lot and my depend a
the retention might change
quite drastically and then last one up
Tao usually improvers with life with the
with the with the life of the of the
game because my users more loyal the
ones that pay they tend to stay longer
so my other will will improve so let's
look at then what about like if I look
only at pain users this is a the bottoms
of model which is kind of like some
model that also many developers are
looking at and it's basically projecting
the RPP you so the average revenue per
paying users in this case we use a curve
which is a logarithmic one and we can
project very similar case that at day
three just the spending I'm getting $30
very 0.30 I wish $30 at 0.45 at the end
of the day period which is day 180 a
couple of pros in this case so again
relatively easy to calculate and we have
also that usually the number the
percentage of conversions is relatively
stable and we can see that it's going to
be like 1.5 or 2% of users pain and the
cons is usually this this model what I
heard is that it works well when you
have a game that most of the
monetization camera comes up front but
some of the hardcore games or strategy
games that you might have like longer
monetization or the monetization starts
later that cure might be difficult to
fit so let's move to the advanced
predictive models so what means advanced
well notice that the the crystal ball is
getting more sophisticated we're using
like historical data and we are trying
to predict individual lifetime value at
a in a probabilistic way so has some
pros and cons in this case to oops
so the first one is obviously like we
kind of like get an estimate at an
individual level which is very useful
it's usually more accurate and the cons
are we need the second extensive user
data and especially we need to have the
resources and capabilities to
interpretate this data and execute based
on this insight which is very
interesting so and why do we need like
predictive models well let me just
illustrate with with a very very simple
example we have two users download they
are both of them have sunglasses but
doesn't it's not any related in any way
and they start like buying sand
so you can see like Rick is a heavy
buyer and then Gavi it is like a more
constant but less purchases so if we
look at certain models or if we look at
the past we can think that Rick at this
stage if you look at forward 280 days
would be more valuable than Gavi however
many of these probabilistic models tell
us that indeed gabby is more likely to
make a purchase and okay you might not
like why is that and how is that how do
we do that well I'm not gonna like talk
about any model in particular but I'm
sorry I'm going to talk about one model
in particular I'm not going to recommend
it because I'm not getting any any it's
an open source model but this is one
model that we are actually looking here
at Google many times it's called a buy
TDD model it's open source it's backed
by academia and buy some Wharton
researchers it's based on these two
models which is the pareto in MIDI and
the busy Nvidia model and I kind of like
I recommend you to have a look because
it's quite simple and it's mighty might
help you in this if you're thinking
about like a predictive model so it's
based on two sub models one is actually
looking at the likelihood of making a
transaction and the other one would be
looking at the value like what is going
to be the feature average or the value
of those transactions so just to
illustrate how it works I'm gonna use
the same example so we have Rick Rick
bought a lot of times and the likelihood
of making a transaction is based on two
variables which is recency so we are
assuming that the most recent that you
did a transaction is the more likely
that you're gonna make another one and
then the frequency which is like how
many times did you buy so we're assuming
basically that I use it that buys a lot
during a long period of time it's going
to be more likely that it's going to buy
again so Rick bought a lot but only very
like in the first five days which means
that then he's probably very like you
could see the colors and is in the dark
dark blue which means like very likely
he's not going to buy again however we
look at Gaby she bought very very little
and then we can see that in this case
like the light
of mine and this is again this is a
model that is done based on research and
empirically also we can see that she's
also by she's gonna be more likely to
buy so what can we get out of these type
of models so most of the times we get
like first the probability of being
alive so at a certain point of time
looking forward we can see like okay
this user is going to buy again or not
so the number of transactions that this
person is going to make this user the
expected average or the values for how
much is going to spend and finally the
expected user LTV which is in the end
it's the product of all the other things
so just taking this model as an example
what would be the pros and the cons so
first the pros again we have individual
lifetime value which is interesting it's
open source you can download the the the
Python apk practic it and you can start
by today and it's backed by academia and
empirically and also can be used by for
other purposes I think this is
interesting because some people are
saying well you're only taking purchases
but we can think about also some events
like for example I don't know like level
one you could even consider that and
estimate the likelihood of playing other
levels on the cons what do we find well
as I said before it works with in-app
purchases us today if we think about
advertising would be a little bit more
challenging because of the number of
events that this is registering and
requires significant amount of data okay
so this would be the model so which one
is the best so again it's quite hard
because every model has the AIDS pros
and cons I would say that personally we
will try to look at predictive models
whenever it's possible there's many of
them this the one that I explained is
just one of them but there's others that
could be useful and I'll try to look at
these whenever we have these are the key
points into consideration so what is the
current situation of the game have we
launched it a while ago and we have the
data what is the primary business model
that we're looking the type of game and
finally do we if we have this
information about individual item value
can we do actually something with it
we're just gonna let it
there and we actually do not have
resources because we need to do
something else right so is that all well
actually when talking about lifetime
value there's other things that people
are considering developers so most of it
at first is most of developers they are
looking at net LTV and profitability
rather than gross LTV so they are
already subtracting in some of the costs
then the second one is we are looking at
very long term lifetime values like 180
days
farther on beyond you might think about
like maybe looking at discounting it
then business models many of you are
using to business models at the same
time in-app purchases and advertising so
one good way to think about like how
would you integrate both of them and you
would look at all your users from both
business models at the same time and
then lastly we see a general trend in
the business is in the mobile gaming
industry a lot of multiplayer online
games that might need indeed to assign
some monetary value to those users that
they generate some liquidity you don't
want to find yourself playing against a
board again and again and again over and
if you think about other things so
virality has a very very important
function in UA but it a priori it
doesn't affect the lifetime value
because you're augmenting the equity of
players and I'm putting that example
over there but it shouldn't affect the
overall lifetime value because you're
just adding new new users the equity of
those paying users still is very
important from a UI perspective because
you're bringing another user with with
that user that your acquire and then
last two things would be frequency of
calculation so how freaking are you
calculating I wouldn't recommend daily
but I would say like depending on the
game if you're constantly updating so
think about this and then lastly the
segment and the cohort analysis the
first one would be top versus lowest
spenders this is a typical one some
developers are looking at geographies
obviously and then time a traffic
sources those would be the most typical
ones but there might be others that
you're currently overlooking so with
these
so what are the tips and best practices
so there's some tips to improve I asked
many of the developers what would you do
like to improve the LTV calculation
right so the first one is forget about
like vanity metrics that they are not
used that you not used in the end I put
downloads but sometimes because of
registered users we might argue these
but in the end like you won't occur only
about like those metrics that are
relevant for an LTV calculation in this
case for example active users cost of
new customers revenues and profit the
plan thoroughly it's super important to
like try to plan in advance rather than
just going reactive and trying to maybe
delete events that they are not used in
your daily decisions integrity of data
super important we need to think about
how we have integrity like data that is
real from the very first day and then
lastly is making trade-offs so if we
don't have enough data to actually take
a decision we might have to think about
how we extract those whales or those
those users that my heaviest spenders
that might have that might bias my
sample so conclusion if you reach to
here like five things that I want to
remember like 5/5 is a lot buddy
so the first one is like LTV has many
usages as of today is very much used for
you a but you you can think about also
from a life of perspective to decide
whether a new functionality or feature
is going to be useful then we can think
about also that it's not an accurate
science so think about when you when
you're talking about lifetime value
think about like a range or like an
interval of confidence lastly if you can
the predictive models might be useful if
you have the data and you have the
capabilities again I'm not saying that
don't use the other ones but just think
about this in case you can actually run
them and then first like four and fifth
point would be decide in advance what
are the things that they've the course
the frequency how frequently you're
going to calculate LTV and finally make
sure that you track the relevant metrics
and then you basically have things like
integrity of data and take the decision
based on on
eleven samples
you